ENTIRE SYSTEM OF GOVERNANCE AND
CAN INFUSE JOE BIDEN, CLEARLY WE
WILL BE BEHOLDEN TO THE MALL AND
WILL HAVE CHAPTER IN MY BOOK,
SOCIALISM, A HISTORY OF FAILURE.
ONE THING IS CERTAIN.
REGARDLESS OF WHATEVER NAME THEY
CALL IT, WHATEVER COUNTRY THEY
TRIED IT, LOFTY PROMISES THAT
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE TAKEN
CARE OF, SOCIALISM ALWAYS
RESULTS IN BROKEN PROMISES,
WIDESPREAD MISERY, DRAMATIC
INCREASES OF POVERTY, CARNAGE,
CORRUPTION, LOSS OF FREEDOM, AND
ONE PARTY RULE.
EVERY SINGLE MARXIST STATE
THROUGHOUT HISTORY IS AN UTTER
FAILURE.
STILL, IN ORDER TO SHORE UP HIS
RADICAL BASE, NOW BOWING DOWN TO
EXTREMISTS AND TAPPING
BERNIE SANDERS AS HIS CHIEF
ECONOMIC CZAR TO RELIEVE
PLAGIARIZING AS USUAL FOR
SOCIALIST PLATFORM WORD FOR
WORD.
REMEMBER, BERNIE SANDERS USED TO
BE A PARIAH NOT LONG AGO INSIDE
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, AN
OUTLIER.
AND IT WAS A COALITION TOGETHER.
JUST BASICALLY TOLERATED AMONG
PARTY LEADERSHIP AND ANNOYANCE
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY AND PRETTY
MUCH HAD INSANE SOCIALIST IDEAS.
NOW HE’S CALLING THE SHOTS
INSIDE THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN
BECAUSE JOE IS DESPERATE AND AS
THE PRESIDENT CALLED IT THE
BOLSHEVIK BURNING MANIFESTO AND
MAYBE THAT’S WHY BIDEN IS ALSO
ADOPTING THE RADICAL LEFT WAR ON
POLICE.
REMEMBER THE POLICE HAVE BECOME
THE ENEMY, HE SAID FUNDING
ABSOLUTELY WILL BE REDIRECTED
AWAY FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT.
HOW DO YOU THINK THAT’S GOING TO
WORK OUT IN SEATTLE OR ANY OF
THESE OTHER CITIES?
BY NOW SUPPORTING $0 BAIL FOR
CRIMINALS AND YESTERDAY ON
TWITTER SUGGESTING THAT MICHAEL
BROWN, THE FERGUSON INCIDENT,
WAS KILLED BECAUSE OF RACIST
POLICE.
HE TWEETED "IT’S BEEN SIX YEARS
SINCE MICHAEL BROWN’S LIFE WAS
TAKEN IN FERGUSON, REIGNITING A
MOVEMENT.
WE MUST CONTINUE THE WORK OF
TACKLING SYSTEMIC RACISM AND
REFORMING POLICING."
THE OWN DOJ CONCLUDED THAT THE
OFFICER DARREN WILSON ACTED IN
SELF-DEFENSE AND AFTER AN
INVESTIGATION THERE, THEY
CONCLUDED THAT THAT SHOOTING WAS
JUSTIFIED.
BY THE WAY, IT WASN’T BIDEN ON
BARACK OR JOE AND BARACK THAT
IMPLEMENTED POLICE REFORM IN
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM, THAT
WOULD BE DONALD TRUMP.
THEY HAD EIGHT YEARS, THEY HAD
BALTIMORE AS WELL.
THEY DID NOTHING.
WAS ALSO CLEARED DARREN WILSON
OF WRONGDOING BY TWO STATE
PROSECUTORS IN THEIR
INVESTIGATION.
IN THESE STATED POLICIES, THEY
END UP SUPPORTING THE ANTIPOLICE
ANARCHISTS.
JUST LISTEN, NEVER SAID A GOOD
WORD THAT I’VE HEARD ABOUT
POLICE, AND THE 99% THAT PROTECT
AND SERVE AND PUT THEIR LIVES ON
THE LINE FOR US, THE 9/11 COPS
THAT ARE GOING UP AS EVERYBODY
WENT DOWN FOR THE COPS THAT WENT
OUT IN AN OPEN BALL FIELD
AGAINST GUY IN CAMOUFLAGE AND
HIDING WITH A RIFLE, ALMOST A
DEATH SENTENCE, BUT DID IT
ANYWAY AND OF COURSE, WE KNOW
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THOSE IN
CHARGE OF WORK TO DISMANTLE AND
DEMONIZE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
LOOK AT THE GREAT CITY OF
PORTLAND, CITY COUNCIL THEY ARE
WORKING TO DEFUND THE POLICE
ALSO AND FOR WEEKS CITY LEADERS
REFUSING TO STOP VIOLENT RIOTS
AT A FEDERAL COURTHOUSE DOWNTOWN
IN THIS WEEKEND TORCHING THE
POLICE UNION BUILDING.
MEANWHILE IN NEW YORK CITY,
CONRAD de BLASIO SLASHING THE
CITY’S POLICE BUDGET BY A
BILLION DOLLARS, DISBANDING THE
PRESTIGIOUS UNDERCOVER MOST
SUCCESSFUL ANTI-CRIME UNIT, ALSO
TEAMING UP WITH GOVERNOR CUOMO
LETTING VIOLENT CRIMINALS OUT OF
JAIL WITH ZERO BAIL POLICIES,
NOW SHOOTINGS IN NEW YORK HAVE
NEARLY DOUBLED OVER 2019 ALREADY
AS OF AUGUST 1ST SURPASSED ALL
THE SHOOTINGS A YEAR AGO, STILL
FIVE MONTHS TO GO.
THEN THERE IS THE CITY OF
CHICAGO, REFUSING TO PROSECUTE
SCORES OF VIOLENT PERPETRATORS
ALTOGETHER.
THE COOK COUNTY STATE ATTORNEY
TIM FOX IS NOW DISMISSED MORE
THAN 25,000 FELONY CASES
INCLUDING MURDER CHARGES AND
OTHER SERIOUS OFFENSES.
THAT’S 35% MORE DISMISSALS THAN
HER PREDECESSOR.
AS A RESULT, MURDERS ARE UP 55%,
SHOOTINGS UP 45%, AND JUST THIS
WEEKEND, MOBS OF CRIMINALS
LOOTING, VANDALIZING STORY AFTER
STORY AFTER STORY AND CHICAGO’S
FAMOUS MAGNIFICENT MILE AREA.
THE CARNAGE AND CHAOS WAS
COMPLETELY OUT OF CONTROL.
BY THE WAY, THINK THOSE STORES
ARE GOING TO REBUILD AND COME
BACK?
ONE INDIVIDUAL RAMMING A CAR
INTO A BUSINESS TO GAIN ACCESS
AND AS YOU CAN SEE FROM OF THE
MOST ICONIC NEIGHBORHOODS NOW IN
DOWNTOWN CHICAGO HAVE DESCENDED
INTO ABSOLUTE ANARCHY LIKE ALL
THESE OTHER CITIES RUN BY THE
LIBERAL DEMOCRATS FOR DECADES.
ALL TOLD, 13 POLICE OFFICERS
INJURED IN THE MAYHEM, TWO
PEOPLE SHOT, 38 OTHERS ACROSS
THE CITY AND WHAT IS BEING